jackseptical
sorry okay it came in a little hot on
that one shoot yourself
maybe I did let me do that again yeah
[Music]
you think you're so smart don't you not
even a little bit
because today we're checking out are you
smarter than a fifth grader oh I knew
that was gonna be the reaction no this
is the type of video where I'm like
should I ever record this for myself no
I don't want to look stupid I don't want
people to know how dumb I really am if
there's anything that dumb we'll just
cut it out what age is fifth grader
because we didn't use that grading
scheme how do you grade your schemes I
don't know what grades are okay okay who
am I trying to be smarter than there
10 to 11. okay 10 to 11 year olds are
smart no no they're not they're really
dumb it's gonna be smarter than I am no
you know what [ __ ] this yeah I'm gonna
be smarter than a 10 year old yeah we'll
do it together all right here we go
question one dick City how many cups are
in 28 fluid ounces
use the metric system 700 mils is like
16 ounces I think 700 mL why did you
know that I don't I think because I
ordered a drink somewhere in America and
I was like okay how much is 16 ounces
they have 700 milliliter drinks in
America God damn yeah and that's just
coffee
okay so you said that was 1.6 I
so it makes sense it's 3.5 then is that
your answer yeah it's definitely not 14
that's way too high I would have guessed
either of these I have no clue
[Music]
it's only because 7 goes into 28 easy
what is 3.5 we are smart Jack we are so
stop using cups stop using ounces stop
using like feet inches I Gotta Be Honest
Jack I had the same opinion but inches
actually makes a lot more sense than
centimeters yes how because you build
stuff in inches it's way more convenient
it tells you to it's way more convenient
I go here I go to the get stuff song
it's like oh can you do this 600 621
this is like no I wish I could just tell
them inches sure my table is like 32
inches off the ground that's easier to
say than 60 or whatever yeah
but when you're trying to cut a table or
something and it's like oh it's five and
three eighths inches
should be thrown against the American
education system sorry
which we are clearly smarter though okay
no I think you're right I think you're
right we just had the quiz here I forgot
about the three quarters and stuff
that's done what white puffy clouds are
known as fair weather clowns
again I have no [ __ ] clue I think
it's cumulonimbus but cumulus sounds so
familiar as well the only one I
recognize is cumulus I never heard of a
culinuminous well I don't need to know
clouds in everyday life like walking
around the park with everyone being like
Oh it's very cumulative today you've
just described what's wrong with the the
school system
the kids need to be taught about taxes
laws the only experience I have a class
is look at that client it's pretty yeah
what does that look like is that dogs is
that a cumulative I Nimbus as a word
just pick it pick it it's all on me
I should have known
I was just about to say as well it
sounds like cumulus cumulonimbus like
they go in layers
okay you're smarter than a fifth grader
I'm not because I wasn't sure I can just
imagine like 10 year olds watching this
video like it's cute
yeah what are you contributing to
society huh yeah what's your major in
college idiot
but I haven't gone to college yet
between
1455 and 1485 The War of Roses took
place in what country I'm so glad to put
the years in there because I would have
been so confused
[Music]
what the War of the Roses I I thought we
would have this in the bag Jack I gotta
be honest with you now I'm getting
worried fifth graders learning this
isn't it the worst when you're you were
taught to learn dates did they do that
in Ireland yeah yeah dates for battles
and stuff like why there's a lot of
dates there's like Irish Independence
and when we got our independence from
England and things like that you love
talking about that all the time every
conversation
look it's all I have
I want to say France but the War of the
Roses I feel like did anything that
sounds British to me yeah but I don't
know I can't name a single war in that
period it's a toss of the coin on this
one okay let's do the classic
[Music]
it's France it's saying
no I've known it would have been a
French name if it was in France series
of civil war is fought over the English
Throne I've already forgotten about it I
don't care
why should I care I just went to the
Tower of London to see like all the
torture devices and everything I got so
much history there's so many King
George's come on we have a lot more
questions we can do this a common type
of radio wave is referred to as a VHF I
wanted to say VHS what do the letters
VHF stand for video frequency
very high frequency very I would have
said variable high frequency because
it's scientific yeah it does very high
just sounds dumb I've never heard of VHF
before Well it can't be video homing
frequency because it's a radio wave yeah
I was just about to say that too
I'm glad we uh came to that conclusion
early instead of picking that one
variable just because it sounds more
scientific yeah I agree and radio waves
go [ __ ]
I just want to say radio waves go up and
down and they vary a lot this is very
high frequency what scientists came up
with that it's less effort to just say
very high frequency than VHF okay no not
really [ __ ]
[Laughter]
God damn these stupid 10 year olds why
are 10 year olds learning these they
don't know this I can't they don't know
don't yell at them
what is a very high regular day yeah
what does the HF stand for where was the
Battle of the Roses
if Tres is facing north it's Trey's a
name I thought you're speaking French
and turn 90 degrees to his right what
direction is he now facing well I can
tell you this one one two three East
okay Jack you didn't say anything
you kept talking I didn't want to talk
over you and I was like wait 360 Degrees
would be all the way back around so
halfway would be
yeah stupid children you don't know this
one but they didn't know that go face
East
do you want to read some sorry I feel
like a frog what the class is frog damn
you're so fast
oh god oh no now you said frog you were
so sure of frog the classic Hands
Christian Andersen fairy tale the real
princess is better known as The Princess
and the I don't recognize princesses
it's princess in the p no yeah wait what
am I thinking of something in the Frog I
think it's that Disney movie that they
did recently yeah I thought that was
based on that but Princess and the p is
the one where she like has a p under her
mattress yeah why do we know that story
are we lucky I'm not sure to be honest
yeah
okay p
ee oh thank God yeah he I was so yes I I
locked in frog way too early on that I
apologize
you were trying to show up a little bit
weren't you I I just saw frog I saw
princess it connected in my head I
shouldn't do that
that's how people online jump to
conclusions and assumptions yeah which
word contains a long vowel sound in the
following sentence dogs like tennis
balls long bow they must be balls right
it balls isn't an answer
because I was thinking the exact same
thing I'd say dogs it must be dogs then
dogs like is quick tennis is quick yeah
dog
no oh no oh no we're done what's a vowel
I don't know the English I can blame my
English at least a e i o u okay 10 10 is
it what was the thing like like it
doesn't have a long that doesn't have a
long vowel sound that feels like a trick
question maybe lie like like dogs this
is like a tennis balls there's no way I
fifth grader knows this that's weird it
fifth grade or her dog and goes for the
answer dog but the problem isn't that
Jack the problem is that we try to use
logic here and it didn't work
look I'm Irish you're Swedish I have an
accent you don't speak English as your
first language it's fine yeah yeah let's
play with that yeah oh capitals okay
Budapest is the capital of what European
country I know I want to say Hungary no
it's not sorry is it not no is it
Austria oh God what if I [ __ ] this up
now I'm gonna worry I've been to Portico
is it Portugal I think it is Portugal
Budapest does not sound like a
Portuguese word I know [ __ ] now don't
worry you think it's hungry I think it's
Portugal just because Budapest sounds
Hungarian but I I honestly have no idea
what the capital I know what the capital
of Hungary is we've trusted your
intuition in the past and we've gotten
wrong so I'll leave exactly I'll take
the blame for it
oh we are so bad Jack I said hungry what
are you saying we're so bad
we are so dumb what's the cat
I feel like as soon as I hear it as soon
as I hear it I knew it yeah the worst
part is I've been to Lisbon and I had a
great time what's the capital of Ireland
uh Ireland City
[Music]
my God man
he gives it a d a dumpling yeah thank
you see if you had something hell on the
other one I got it all right can we
still be friends now is that how that
works yeah okay guys Stockholm is the
capital of swedeness whatever yes you
are correct everyone knows that
now a National Historical Park what site
was headquarters for George Washington's
Army in the winter of
1777-78. it's a Bunker Hill Bunker Hill
is the only one I've heard of really I
was just memeing uh last time we went
with my intuition it would be bad sure
Bunker Hill and we were all there was no
intuition about it it was just I've
never heard of the other
oh my God we have like scrap the video
objects or something no it's fine live
in it I don't know it's either what is
the more predicate in the following
sentence Taylor body slammed her
opponent what what is a predicate
I'm in hell I'm back to school I hate
this yeah this sucks I
I have never been taught any of this
[ __ ] in school this is American history
or American Education what did you learn
in fifth grade I don't remember I
remember studying the Titanic
it's all right yeah yeah maybe if that
question comes up we'll get a point yeah
let's get in start saying off all the
knowledge you know about nothing so
people know you're smart what is the
simple predicate in the following
sentence Taylor Taylor body slammed her
opponent predicate would imply like to
predicate something to what does that
mean go before it right like maybe it
was the scene for it or something to me
my intuition says body slam yeah that's
where my mind was going so but that also
feels like too easy and everything's
been like a trick question we've gone
with intuition been wrong we've logiced
it out been wrong yeah you're just
randomly been wrong full circle back to
my intuition
[Applause]
let's go
eat [ __ ]
high definition okay a prism is a solid
figure that has many
congruent base what's the Congress
congruent I mean is I think means just
like together or like they converge or
like
I could be really wrong well it has all
the colors how many color is more than
four I will go six well see the thing is
a rainbow has seven colors doesn't it uh
green doesn't count
why what
I thought you're saying this from
somebody's scientific school
yes I know these things isn't there a
thing though like one of the colors
isn't actually a color and you know it
doesn't matter I don't care it's six
two
I was about to say it's four or six
there's no way it's two look up look up
a picture of a prism we've all seen that
album cover there it is adding two there
let me tell you that
understand the question it's a solid
figure that has many congruent bases
okay so prism oh so it's just like oh
like opposing just the base of it where
life would go through is that it all
right it's like the top and bottom of it
cool cool what a great or like we've
been we've been rigged this is [ __ ]
we're getting shafted by this from now
on all correct oh sure in 1821 Moses and
Stephen Austin received 18 000 acres of
land and what would become what U.S
state
Texas Moses lived in 1821 Austin Texas
Moses and Stephen Austin founded Austin
Texas do you really think his Texas
no no no let's think about this do you
jump to conclusions before
sure okay logic it out for me but nobody
why Texas it's just because they have
the name Austin oh Austin is a place in
Texas you're right that is good logic
you're right
you know we always make fun of Americans
for not knowing geography right well
this is their payback of like [ __ ] they
learn in USA for some reason
it's a Powerhouse or the sound like oh
yeah it's like Find Sweden on a map and
everyone's like is it here and it's like
Denmark
Norway that's close at Lisa that's true
I would be happy if they got that I'm
just happy if they clicked Europe are
you from Sweden oh like a chocolate I'm
like yeah we have chocolate
and like the ski I'm like yeah you're
right we do have skiing too we have snow
I think you mean Switzerland but thank
you yeah which of the following is a
homophone for the word one
you have never in my entire life heard
of a homophone lost is an antonym of it
right like the opposite yes I know an
antonym correct a synonym is one that's
similar homophone I think is how it
sounds so I think it's one like one okay
that makes sense damn Irish logic
Irish logic wins let's go I was gonna
say like what's the language in English
I actually kind of know a few things and
I'm like no I got one wrong earlier
never mind no no no you got it that was
great oh math okay math you're much
better at math than I am
no I'm not why would you say that if you
take the square root of 16 and add it to
the square root of nine the answer you
get is the square root of what number so
you take the square root of 16 which is
4 and add it to the square root of 9
which is three so you get a square root
sorry you're right the answer you get is
the square root of what other number so
49 they try to trick is yes but they
kind of like read that real slow I I
read squared for some reason that's why
I got lost okay uh Mexico is bordered on
the south by Belize and what other
Central American country
yep
I'm so sorry Mexico I have no idea about
your geography I don't
need geography I barely know Europe
Guatemala sounds the funniest
what do you mean sounds the funniest
Guatemala it goes off your tongue you
mean it's the most fun you can't say
It's the funniest
no it's the funniest okay well you don't
know English go back to school Jack
Guatemala house
[Music]
yeah yeah you say that after you see the
answer okay I see how this goes I'm just
really smart
which of the following is a scientific
term for an organism that makes its food
from inorganic materials so not
embryotroph because that's an embryo
which is an egg which is organic
autotroph might be the thing like it
makes it from that just means it's
autonomous I don't know I don't know
what heterotroph means heterosexual I
want to say autotroph okay I'll Trust
you in the wish let's go
nice
we should technically get like because
we have three options we should
technically get a third right if we
don't get even a third right then we're
technically dumber than a monkey that
would literally just guess the answers
well that's the thing a monkey wouldn't
try and use logic yeah they would just
guess that they would get a third right
fifth graders could go to hell we're
gonna beat the monkeys okay you are dumb
when paired with a helping verb like
have or has this word go turns into what
word in the past tense boing have has go
gone gone it's go gone gone you have
something he has something you go there
he goes there it's goes are gone because
it would be have had then if it was gone
I think that's my I'm one of my last two
brain cells at the moment Jack I gotta
be honest with you I don't I'm
completely overlying on you at this
point
it was gone I thought it was a trick
see a monkey would get it right because
he doesn't overthink yeah
which of the following words can be used
as an adjective it has to be smooth it's
a describing word
smooth easy see now I'm second guessing
everything yeah right because it seems
like trick question all of it all right
we're almost there round the number 350
to the nearest hundred
400 right because if it's 50 or over you
round up I didn't know that was a rule
to be honest with you well that's the
thing dude does everybody use that rule
or is that just something that I heard
growing up and it's like if you've heard
it I would definitely go with it yeah
nice monkeys what
what is the correct spelling for a
system built to carry water oh see I
want to say Aqua duct because Aqua is
water but this could be a thing where
it's like in ancient Greece it was
actually spelled aqueduct
[Music]
I want to go for the obvious answer I'm
gonna go with aqued that just because
is that conduct
[Music]
ORS speaks in Thailand it's based on
Latin so you were totally on point with
that yeah I was like how far back are we
going are we just going with a
modernized spelling uh let's go Martin
say you need the help thank you Mercier
she came in clutch in the end does she
know anything about the rivers in U.S
which of these River lies entirely
within the U.S well I only know the
Mississippi River Colorado is like North
ish right I feel like that might go
through Canada but I don't know how far
north Colorado is yeah it's not like a
herd of places like Colorado maybe in
Canada too I'm saying this as if I
actually know anything
UConn I have no idea where Yukon river
is so yeah let's we intuited two of the
other answers so let's just it's
Mississippi
I thought for sure that passed through
all the way if Kevin plans on visiting
the three tallest mountains in the world
what continent will he be visiting I
just realized that I have no idea where
Mount Everest is it's in Asia okay yeah
this month average the documentaries
can't say I have a mate I might have to
bookmark those
next time all right last question what
month is named for the Roman god of war
March because it's Mars damn you're fast
let's go [ __ ] yeah all right let's see
the result oh yeah we beat the monkeys
60th percentile that means we passed
right 60 passes right yeah it says
congrats it says
the kids look happy
I'm gonna keep thinking like a monkey
and say we did it next time if we ever
do a test Jack we'll just cheat off each
other and we'll we'll clearly beat the
system hell yeah we did a joke
well I regret it
this is the thing that everyone's so
you're answering these questions in a
video but if they had to do it
themselves how many would you get right
everyone watching this I want you to
actually answer these honestly without
Googling them and see how many you get
yeah and write it in the comments well
they probably played along and was like
yeah I know that that's what I do when I
watch Jeopardy all right right it's
always like oh of course it's that one
because it has that in it
useless information all right and every
single thing we heard here I forgot
battle where's the war of England or
hell yeah
today and if you learn smash like
subscribe check out Jack Channel and see
you next time hit him with the whip
are you control of your internet
experience well take control today with
nordvpn check out nordvpn.com pdfi for
the greatest VPN of all time oh look at
all these trash vpns so
glorious nordvpn nordvpn actually care
about your security and they have a
cyber security awareness campaign for
example lesson one this one's for free
if you connect to a public Wi-Fi anyone
could be hosting that anyone can go to
Starbucks and set up a free cafe Wi-Fi
you want to join or boom got all your
[ __ ] always use a VPN when connecting to
public Wi-Fi rule number one everyone
knows this for only a couple bucks a
month you can protect yourself and of
course nordvpn the greatest VPN has
another level of security with threat
protection you don't even have to
connect to a VPN to use it it adds
another layer protects your downloads
protects from malware malicious trackers
intrusive ads all that stuff bang bang
boom nerd VPN ganji protective but of
course one of the greatest things that I
use for VPN is I have it on my TV if I
want to watch any streaming service from
another country which since I'm in Japan
right now is very very useful one click
connects super fast
and you can watch whatever you want it's
just one of those things that is always
nice to have and right now if you sign
up with the link in the description
nordvpn.com PewDiePie for a two-year
deal you get additional four months for
free it's an incredible offer I highly
recommend it you won't regret it you
will only miss it and curse it if you
don't have it when you want it I use it
every single day thank you nordvpn for
sponsoring this video